The joe rogan experience.
This may transition into a TSA rant and I apologize if it does cause it's still
fresh in about,
well,
we gotta talk about that.
Anyway,
the biggest fucking government works program that's really going on right now.
Our tax dollars going to create a system to create jobs to demean us and make us
feel like criminals for wanting to take a flight,
a program that is inefficient,
ineffectual by thousands of thousands.
That's hyperbole by hundreds of sorted papers that is inefficient,
ineffectual,
that demeans us,
that leads to lobbyists in government,
kickbacks for these corporations that make machines that scan us and take nude
photos.
This essentially for the folks at me off for the folks that do the Tsa,
it is a shit job.
You're dealing with people that don't want to be there.
I'm dealing with people that don't want to comply and in their defense,
look,
there's that fucking classic Stanford study that we've brought up over and over
again of what happened when they just had college students have one person in
charge or the ward.
The other person is the prisoner.
When they,
when you do that,
people abuse Pete Radio and radiation.
It to me is is a moot point.
Like,
yeah,
I don't think I deserve it.
I don't write this violation.
It's a rights violation.
Plus the rapid scan corporation,
which was one of the two big corporations that had like,
you know the $70 million contracts to install these machines,
they were funding Chertoff who was the ex head of the Homeland Security
Administration.
Like they've increased their lobbying five five by like 50% or something since
2008 and 2010 that was the last study I read.
So Lord knows how much money they're spending now to kick.
They get kickbacks to people in power to do these no bid contracts to put in
these machines,
which by the way,
most most security and defense experts tell you that they can actually detect
the plastic explosives that could blow up at seven 47 like they can't actually
detect it.
Plus there was a case in Florida,
just not only black,
probably two years ago,
where hundreds of thousands of the photos from people going through those
machines because it does store photos,
even though it doesn't display them.
Those photos were hacked and it was,
they said,
we don't store these photos,
they don't get taken,
but they have a nude picture of you somewhere.
I think metal detectors are good.
I do.
I think the idea of checking your bags is good.
There's too many cons.
There are certainly,
there are certainly there should be a standard of protection,
you know,
metal detector,
how do you want to scan the baggage?
That's fine.
But I think we've drawn the line way too far and we've drawn up the x ray
machine in the Austin airport and it's right next to one of those rapid scan
body scanning machines.
Right.
And there is a long line for the rapid scan machine and that's when they say,
oh that lines get long.
Come on through the x rays.
So right away I'm like,
you know what?
If this is integral to my safety,
you're now chucking my safety out the window for the convenience factor of
cycling people through security.
Well,
they really saying that it's not safe and these are really what they're saying
the rabbits can thing or the,
no,
no.
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about if we need those,
those body scanning machines because they can detect a whole bunch of stuff that
a traditional x ray can't.
Oh,
is that when it gets to inconvenient?
Because the line is too long.
You're now throwing my safety out the window.
That seems inconsistent.
It seems wrong.
Right?
Crazy.
But I'm in line to go through the x and then randomly they do the,
uh,
you need to go through the rapid scan machines.
So I said,
can I just go through the x Ray?
No,
you can't.
Now they're angry with me because I even asked that.
So I opt out as I normally do.
My belongings go through the machine.
Now I can't see them.
I say,
Hey,
I can't see my laptop.
I can't see my phone.
I can't see any of that stuff.
It's over there.
You're la,
your belongings are fine.
How do I know that?
I can't see them?
They didn't give anybody to do it.
So I'm already on edge.
Right?
I always hit it.
Always feel like whenever I take a fucking jet blue flight,
this is gonna be my occupied moment.
It's gonna end with pepper spray to the face and I'm gonna get handcuffed even
though as polite as can be.
And I just,
I just want someone to watch my shit right?
I get stuck in a glass box where I'm next to a girl that couldn't have been more
than six years old.
Um,
she has a handicap.
She's in a wheelchair and there was something mentally wrong with her.
She was stemming,
she was rocking.
She was pulling her hair and crying because there were three TSA agents trying
to tell her to lift her arms so they can swab her clothes,
swab her wheelchair,
the back pad,
the tires,
the wheels,
everything.
Her Dad is there on the brink.
You can imagine how traumatic it is to try to bring somebody in a special needs
child through an airport in general.
But now they've been selected for special screening and he has to try to explain
to his daughter who was having a fit.
Rightfully so as strangers are groping her and you know,
swiping,
swabbing her seat.
He's trying to calm her down.
Well,
you know,
by holding an iPad and her face and doing whatever he can to get her to relax.
Do I have to lift her out of the seat?
He asked.
Yes you do.
He's trying to lift her up.
She's fighting it.
My heart is breaking for this guy.
The reason I'm sitting in this glass box is because after my pat down,
they ran my little piece of cloth or they ran the gloves and the piece of cloth
that they swipe the bottom of my feet with through a machine.
Like by the way,
machines would lead,
which we spent more than $30 million on to install and airports in this machine
said I tested positive for nitrates.
I had that will happen one.
Yeah.
And I pulled up.
Oh,
so what's a nitrate?
Well sir,
it's a,
you know,
that could be used as a chemical.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Well,
it's a chemical be used in a lot of things.
It doesn't,
this isn't a,
it's not a bad thing.
It's not a bad thing.
Like this isn't a problem and I go,
no,
it is a problem because I have a flight to catch and I want to know like why I'm
being detained longer.
While you're tested positive for nitrates,
we have to give you a,
an even more thorough screening.
Okay,
well what else can test positive for nitrates?
Guy Couldn't answer it.
Second person couldn't answer it.
Third person ask you if you had been to a farm.
No they did not.
But the third guy finally said,
well the,
the head of the security mob there said,
well if you've walked on grass that has fertilizer on it,
then you might test positive for nitrates.
Even a certain heart medications that seniors take and test positive for
nitrates.
So I'm now stuck in a glass box,
detached from my valuables watching this poor girl having a meltdown.
As these three people are going to love her and I start to cry cause it just,
it breaks my heart that this is happening.
This poor guy is having to go through this and I,
you know,
I go to put my hand on a shoulder and tell him like,
I'm sorry,
you have to go through this.
And he looks back and he's choked up.
I mean he's been in there for a good 15 minutes trying to calm down his
daughter.
So then I start questioning,
why are you guys doing this?
And I'm being polite and being calm,
being everything you could possibly be while asking how much longer this is
going to take because I have a flight to catch.
They grab my belongings and start walking them away and go,
excuse me.
What are you doing?
Like you're,
you're coming here to this private screening room.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to be in a private screening room.
I want this enhanced pat down to happen right here because I want my girlfriend
to videotape it.
Well,
no,
no sir.
You're going by this time,
my belongings are in the frosted glass private screening room.
Now I'm in the private screening room with them and there's a giant placard that
says this is a private security room.
There was no filming whatsoever.
If a tree,
if a TSA employee tells you to stop filming,
you must seats filming immediately.
You do have the right to call in a witness to be there.
And I'm thinking,
why can't the camera be my witness?
Because if I'm traveling alone,
who else am I going to call fucking Ghostbusters am I gonna Bring Tsa in here?
So I'm in a glass box with two dudes by myself.
He swabs me down with the gloves and then he says,
I'll be right back.
I have to test this glove goes,
puts his hand on the handle of the door with the glove on it that he just wiped
me down,
opens it up and walks out on his merry way.
So I looked to the other guy who's left in the room.
I'm like,
what the fuck was that?
And it was like the first time I had cursed and he goes,
what do you mean?
I'm like,
he just swapped my body down with that glove.
Then grabbed the handle.
If someone in her earlier did have explosives on them and he grabbed that handle
with that glove.
That's now on my test.
Why is any testing right here?
There's a machine in the room.
Oh Sir.
That that machine's calibration is off.
That's why it's here.
Oh,
it happened in the room?
Cause the calibration is off.
Yeah.
There's a tag on it that says it needs to be serviced.
Okay.
So I'm waiting five minutes go by.
I've strike up conversation with the guy.
I hate that that little girl out there in the wheelchair that's having the fit
and I can still hear her having a poor meltdown out there.
Why are they out there?
Well he tested positive for nitrates as well.
Oh he did?
Yeah.
Why is the girl there?
Oh,
she tested positive for nitrates.
Oh.
So all three of us have tested positive for nitrates with the one machine that's
out there.
You've got another one in here that need servicing and recalibration and you
think there's nothing wrong with this situation.
Guy Comes back,
tells me,
I'm clear,
I leave the room and I see the father is still there struggling with his
daughter and I'm like,
I'm again like moved to tears.
And I asked this guy,
tell me as a human being,
do you think this is right?
Do you think this treatment for this poor girl is right?
And he goes,
sir,
she tested positive for nitrates and went right.
I get that.
But there are many other countries who deal with terrorism on a far greater
level than we do who have far more swifter and more and more common sense
approach to security that doesn't demean their citizenry.
That doesn't cost them millions of taxpayer dollars.
Do you think that that's right,
that that girl is having a meltdown,
you're swabbing her wheelchair,
do you really think she's a terrorist?
I'm just asking you as a human being.
And there was a long pause and he sort of looked down and looked at his shoes
and I thought,
good,
I'm finally going to have a moment,
a real moment here as a human being is going to take off that TSA helmet for a
second.
And he looked up and looked me right in the eyes and says,
she tested positive for nitrates.
And that's when I realized,
this is it.
This is a lost cause.
This is a losing battle here.
Yeah,
yeah.